Игорь А.: Да, благодарю, что присоединились ко встрече. Еще раз, цель нашего звонка в том, чтобы у наших экспертов немножко с ними мне познакомиться, рассказать о продукте и, соответственно,
Игорь А.: может быть, его улучшить перед тем, как мы его запустим. Поэтому я вот, как вам удобнее, на ты, на вы? На ты вполне можно. Да, хорошо, будем тогда на ты. Я начну с первого вопроса.
Игорь А.: Немножко можешь рассказать, пожалуйста, про свою деятельность? С кем в основном работаешь? То есть, кто твои клиенты, так сказать? У
Юлия К.: меня два образования. Первое – художественное в России по фэшнам. И второе – в Великобритании по электрации. Далее я работала 6 лет в Британской школе дизайна в Москве. И таким образом
Юлия К.: у меня случилось понимание международного образования и требований к портфолио. И с 2017 года я ушла в свободное плавание, в репетиторство, и я почувствовала для себя эту нишу в плане
Юлия К.: подготовки международного портфолио. Да, у меня есть как бы абитуриенты, которые приготовлены для российских вузов, это высшая школа экономики и британская школа дизайна. Но такой как
Юлия К.: бы основной для меня, ну какой -то эндурос, это были как бы дети, которые уезжают учиться за рубеж из России. на дизайн я принципиально не работаю с подготовкой в академические вузы
Юлия К.: троганов помарки вот мне интересно помочь человеку раскрыться то есть как бы в рамках моего курса мы пробуем разные техники и я помогаю человеку нащупать две усиленные стороны то есть
Юлия К.: так как у меня есть и вот это вот видение про моду и про графику и про печатную графику британской школе дизайна я организовал печатную мастерскую по шелтографии и за счет вот этого
Юлия К.: какой -то широты и как бы академического образования в россии вот я помогаю людям именно во -первых правильно выбрать вуз на моду также мне большую архитектура дали кому -то помогаю
Юлия К.: какой -то составе такой вот базы понимания нужно ли им туда
Юлия К.: пожалуй основной момент мы перебираем разное мы пробуем сориентироваться хочется дальше уже когда четко направление выбрана Мы более детально смотрим требования и готовимся к конкретной
Юлия К.: пути.
Игорь А.: Хорошо. А вот в каком возрасте начинает происходить вот эта подготовка? То есть родители, я так понимаю, что обращаются родители все -таки, да? И вот условно говоря, там 8, 9, 10, 11,
Игорь А.: то есть в каком возрасте дети приходят?
Юлия К.: на самом деле довольно разные семьи и как бы такие сознательные подростки
Юлия К.: зачастую родители участвуют на начальном этапе когда они хотят понять
Юлия К.: дети не говорят по -русски несколько раз я брала детей подростков в Москве, у кого, например, родители экспаты, и по -русски на ней все они идут. Для меня тоже интересный опыт, потому
Юлия К.: что три года прожила в Лондоне.
Юлия К.: Мне нравится поддерживать язык, в целом для меня какая -то такая хорошая встряска, что ли, в плане языка.
Игорь А.: Круто, вообще интересный опыт. А как приходят к тебе все эти клиенты, может соцсети, рекомендации, есть какой -то понятный флот? А с
Юлия К.: теми, на самом деле, вот эти 10 лет это был профи и Яндекс .Услуги. А и, собственно, вот еще про клиентуру, которая мне рассказала, это ко мне обращаются в современных художницах. То
Юлия К.: есть, например, человек в кризис, вроде он там, не знаю, 10 лет пишет, как сильно подает, но как бы непонятно, что делать дальше. И как раз вот мое видение, которое, ну, как бы, есть
Юлия К.: насмотренность, есть понимание современных тенденций в искусстве, и я могу человеку вот оказать помощь, если я как бы, не знаю, полгода работа вместе, и как бы происходит какой -то
Юлия К.: прорыв, и как бы помощь в плане, ну, и развитие конспитуальной, и в плане техники.
Юлия К.: Так, я, наверное, ушла от вопроса.
Юлия К.: как обычно
Игорь А.: приходят к тебе как я
Юлия К.: просто не договорил эту фразу и так как клиентура специфическая очень часто работают сарафанно люди передаются другим контакт то есть в данном случае да
Игорь А.: А вот можешь как -то формализировать, условно говоря, сам запрос, как тебе его задают? Условно, поступление в ВУЗ или еще что -то. Как тебя,
Юлия К.: условно
Игорь А.: говоря, передают из уст в уста?
Юлия К.: 80, может быть, 70 -80 % это действительно поступление в ВУЗ и помочь определиться с направлением, потому что зачастую родители не из сферы дизайна и очень сложно ребенку подсказать,
Юлия К.: как это будет. И некоторое направление, как современный жив, очень часто отталкивает людей, потому что это мало связано с профессией. Ну и в контексте современных художников это как
Юлия К.: бы сдвинуться с мертвой точки в современном искусстве, то есть это не обучение рисованию, а это именно какой -то творческий прорыв,
Юлия К.: контекстоварный, продвинуться. Поэтому да, не только найти себя в творчестве, то есть такой запрос найти себя в творчестве, то есть понять, что хочется, в какую сторону.
Игорь А.: А есть, например, непрофильные какие -то запросы и ты не знаешь, что с ними делать, отказываешь или кому -то передаешь?
Юлия К.: Ну, сейчас вот скажу, да, хороший очень вопрос, он действительно со мной случился. На самом деле, последние три года я изучаю психологию и закончила двухлетний курс и связано с тем
Юлия К.: что мой профиль там на профи он как бы спрятался там хорошие отзывы в какой -то момент стали обращаться очень интересные люди которые обращалась девушка с шизофренией и она пришла к
Юлия К.: мне я понимаю что с ней рисовать я понимаю как как художник я могу помочь но при этом я не очень понимаю вот эту базу по психике и последние три года я вложила время и я поняла что
Юлия К.: я вижу в этом свою миссию То есть иногда люди идут в творчество, чтобы выразить себя, и для того, чтобы найти вот эту стабильность, какое -то вот свое хобби, самовыражение, и это помогает
Юлия К.: им жить. И это очень классно, и я к этому нормально отношусь. То есть мне кажется, это важная сейчас тема.
Игорь А.: Да, согласен.
Юлия К.: я думаю она дальше будет более востребован вот но я сама на самом деле до того как я стала учиться на дизайне в текстильном юрисе на самом деле я на год поступала на психологический
Юлия К.: Я бросила, у меня всегда был этот интерес к устройству психики, у меня всегда был запрос на то, чтобы более глубоко человеком понять, что в тренинг творчества может быть сейчас, как
Юлия К.: я могу здесь ему помочь.
Юлия К.: Как -то одно слило другое.
Юлия К.: И как -то
Игорь А.: получается продавать дополнительно какие -то консультации психологические?
Юлия К.: Да, на сегодняшний момент я только -только, как это обучение прошло, закончилось для себя, все это дело сформулировало, поэтому как продукт пока нет, но тем не менее оно созрело.
Юлия К.: Ну, на самом деле, просто это сейчас, даже в последний год, когда я работала с Мартом, вот Алиной, да, на самом деле Март довольно открытый человек был, и на самом деле, мне кажется,
Юлия К.: как раз эти знания, они помогли мне, ну, в какой -то момент просто хотела закончить занятие, потому что он включал камеру, он выключал звук, и как бы, как можно вести онлайн занятие,
Юлия К.: когда человек полностью отключается, вот, но тем не менее у меня хватило мудрости и терпения, и, в принципе, как -то, Вот,
Юлия К.: но это не единичная с ней, это как бы на самом деле такая...
Юлия К.: Да, слышал, хорошие
Игорь А.: отзывы о работе. А вот если говорить в целом про твою аудиторию, не только с MainExperts, какой чек твоя аудитория воспринимает нормально? Они же видят пользу твою, что есть для них
Игорь А.: норма? на
Юлия К.: самом деле у меня сильно разнятся выездные занятия то есть вот сейчас девочка которая современный художник мы работаем не стоит занять за 14000 за два часа
Юлия К.: ну и в целом сейчас к занятиям которые я положил онлайн или когда когда люди по мне, это 8 тысяч за полтора часа.
Юлия К.: Ну, как бы я к этому долго шла, но сейчас она немножко заклеилась.
Игорь А.: Хорошо, тогда я уже больше перехожу к своему продукту, который мы будем сейчас делать. Поэтому такие вопросы уже больше задам, которые меня интересуют с точки зрения твоего интереса
Игорь А.: дополнительного. То есть интересно ли тебе, например, самой будет рекомендовать что -то, что будет являться частью экосистемы MainExperts?
Юлия К.: Ну, задайте вопрос более конкретно, сейчас не очень поняла, о чем вы спрашиваете. Хорошо, я задам
Игорь А.: его по -другому, я просто его конкретнее задам попозже. Вот,
Игорь А.: нормально ли тебе будет, если, например, мы что -то предложим в плане вот есть польза, и у тебя есть семья, которой ты понимаешь, что это пригодится, нормально ли тебе будет рекомендовать?
Юлия К.: Ну, конечно.
Игорь А.: Вот, смотри, я тогда там чуть -чуть загляну вперед, потому что я думаю, что Алина тебе рассказывала или не рассказывала.
Игорь А.: и что это за продукт. То есть мы сейчас как раз -таки готовим продукт, который называется партнерская программа в MainExpert. Мы платформу там уже практически сделали всю и к ней прикручиваем
Игорь А.: партнерскую программу. И в ней, соответственно, таким основным продуктом, там и Марк тот же проходил, и все наши клиенты, которые заходят, они изначально проходят профориентацию. То
Игорь А.: есть это такой продукт, который как раз -таки у нас является базовым. То есть часто приходят поговорить про вуз, про поступление, а мы отматываем на несколько шагов назад и говорим
Игорь А.: о том, что смотри, это все хорошо, вот есть там топ -вузы, это все классно, но чтобы понять действительно, куда тебе идти, нужно определиться с твоими талантами, предрасположенностью,
Игорь А.: психологической предрасположенностью. То есть рассмотреть тебя, разобрать, условно говоря, на атом, и из этого собрать тебе карту, как навигатор обучения.
Игорь А.: Вот я о самом продукте чуть позже расскажу, как там все устроено. Но вот тебе было бы интересно, условно говоря, вот такое, если ты увидишь, что семье это полезно, есть ли те семьи
Игорь А.: на сегодня, которым бы ты, например, могла сказать, окей да они у меня есть я могу прямым отправить ссылку на такой продукт
Юлия К.: здесь смотрите я работаю с людьми которых
Юлия К.: они поступили их в общем -то актуальность она пропадает здесь достаточно такое тонкое горлышко огромный как бы
Юлия К.: с кем я работала но другой стороны да как бы актуально это как бывало вероятно
Юлия К.: но если вы меня рассматриваете как выход на новых клиентов
Юлия К.: не хочу поделиться просто
Юлия К.: меня были достаточно беспечные корейские семьи, которые не говорили по -русски, но опять же мы два года занимались, и сейчас, не знаю, тонкое горлышко, высокие тренки, не тонкое горлышко.
Юлия К.: Ну, я
Игорь А.: потом расскажу, как это горлышко раскрывается. На самом деле мы тоже об этом подумали. Мы же ведем клиентов годами, поэтому предусмотрели и интерес. Мы не просто так порекомендуйте,
Игорь А.: а порекомендуйте за процент, и потом еще есть процент от пакетов по сопровождению. Это я уже далеко вперед забегаю у паровоза. Но в целом, может быть, и не вперед. Могу, в принципе,
Игорь А.: можем перейти, я так вот расскажу как раз -таки.
Игорь А.: Могу даже включить, постримить немножко,
Игорь А.: если будет удобно. Да, то есть что такое, что за продукт мы сейчас готовим? Значит, как я сказал, что на самом деле это профориентация как точка входа. Я вот так вот расшарю.
Игорь А.: И по факту мы что делаем? Когда к нам приходят, мы, соответственно, чтобы построить путь и порекомендовать вообще ВУЗ, выбрать ВУЗ. То есть до этого отматываем до самой профориентации.
Игорь А.: И в партнерской программе предусмотрели выплату в размере 35 % от стоимости, которую партнер будет указывать. То есть как все происходит. Семья платит платформе, платформа обрабатывает
Игорь А.: клиента, выдает отчет после прохождения внутренних тестирований. услуга оказана соответственно там партнеру происходит выплата я позже все расскажу мы решили что цена есть минимальная
Игорь А.: на это на все я почему спрашивал как раз таки прочих такая рекомендуемая розничная цена 20 тысяч рублей ниже которой уходить не нужно но в целом в рынок мы такой продукт сейчас начинаем
Игорь А.: продавать за 35 тысяч по факту мы его продаем дороже мы вот там ультра high network семьям продаем намного дороже то есть это вопрос как раз таки того что мы хотим выйти в более широкий
Игорь А.: рынок и пока что там чуть чуть меньше сама услуга будет в пакете содержать ну про про внутренность там расскажу но цену устанавливает сам партнер в кабинете то То есть в целом можно
Игорь А.: и выше 35, но не ниже 20. Просто чтобы, во -первых, и партнеру было интересно, и нам тоже. То есть какой портрет я описал, почему я спрашивал, с какими людьми работаешь, кто основная
Игорь А.: аудитория. То есть это подростки от 10 до 18 лет. Вот сама процедура, ну, я тоже проходил, у меня трое детей, вот мои старшие дочки проходили, то есть у нас там, наверное, минут 40
Игорь А.: это все заняло, ну, максимум час, может быть, а то и то быстрее. Вот, соответственно, проходится на платформе, то есть мы все это автоматизировали, мы сделали полностью весь этот отчет,
Игорь А.: как цифровой электронный продукт, то есть родитель. Я, моя жена, мы получаем свой отчет, дети получают свой отчет, там есть сильные стороны, там интересы, сферы, то есть очень большой
Игорь А.: подробный. Я прям сам как пользователь такой открыл, вау, вот так, Макс, где ты был раньше? У меня просто старшая дочка, ей 14, уже как раз тоже время подходит выбора направления. Вот,
Игорь А.: соответственно, дальше происходит разбор, мы включаем разбор со специалистом этого всего, и после того, как процедура оказана, отчет выдан, услуга завершается. Вот. Но это как бы первый
Игорь А.: шаг. Мы с этим первым цифровым продуктом работаем. Почему я сказал, что это узкое горлышко расширяется? Потому что дальше мы же делаем уже карту, в которой будет и поступление в ВУЗ,
Игорь А.: и как раз таки в поступлении в ВУЗ различные пакеты, которые будут затрагивать работу с экспертами. Мы внутри платформы будем делать такую систему, что эксперт будет ставить, например,
Игорь А.: процент, который он готов отдавать за его рекомендации. Таким образом, например, вот час там ставит 5 -10 тысяч рублей, но при этом там может поставить 20 % в партнерскую программу.
Игорь А.: Да, и, соответственно, партнер, который привлекает, он тоже. Ну, например, я понимаю, что у меня там ученик по математике есть, ему там нужен дизайн, ну, неважно, там биолог дизайн.
Игорь А.: То есть я рекомендую тебя, ты рекомендуешь меня. И вот начинается вот этот процесс, когда просто человек, который от тебя пришел в систему, ты как партнер, привлекший его, ну, там начинаешь
Игорь А.: как раз таки. Ну, естественно, если прямая рекомендация, то больше, если не прямая, то чуть меньше. То есть мы таким образом хотим количество клиентов увеличить, увеличить как раз -таки
Игорь А.: через цифровые внутренние продукты проходимость нашей системы. То есть мы уже сейчас, в принципе, можем там сотни тысяч клиентов позволяет пропускная система обслуживать одновременно,
Игорь А.: поэтому как бы нагрузку мы продумали. Ну вот как тут написано, что главная ценность для родителей – это ясность. То есть мы, получается, через профориентацию даем им ясность и дальше
Игорь А.: уже сопровождаем их в течение кого -то трех, кого -то пяти лет обучения. Ну и тут есть подсказки, я, соответственно, могу тоже эту презентацию скинуть, потом, что кто наш целевой портрет
Игорь А.: клиента, когда продавать легко, 8 -9 класс, 10 -11 класс, либо когда уже мотивация падает у ребенка, либо постоянные споры, то есть вот эти все моменты мы этому тоже, Обучающий продукт
Игорь А.: мы планируем сделать, то есть мы сейчас, знаешь, этапами. На этой неделе запускаем сам партнерский кабинет, потом там обучающий внутри кабинета, будем материалы догружать, ну и так
Игорь А.: далее. То есть усиливать эту партнерскую программу. Ну, здесь прописан простой путь, я думаю, что там все видно, что там рекомендуешь. Например, внутри создаешь ссылку, рекомендуешь
Игорь А.: семье, отправляешь ее. Например, семья оплачивает, ребенок проходит. То есть завершается процедура,
Игорь А.: суммы ты все видишь. Например, платформа выплачивает. Опять же, про цену минимум 20, рекомендуемая 35, можно и выше. То есть, опять же, тоже, когда продумывал всю эту систему, и внутри
Игорь А.: команды мы общались, как так, если, например, один эксперт порекомендует одну цену, другой эксперт порекомендует другую цену. То есть мы как раз -таки, вот я почему спрашивал, проходишь
Игорь А.: ты какие -нибудь, даешь другие консультации или нет, и вот то, что как раз -таки ты говоришь, что у тебя есть, например, сейчас стремление в психологию разобраться,
Игорь А.: здесь можно будет как раз -таки после прохождения обучения внутреннего
Игорь А.: саму консультацию, которая проходит после прохождения профориентации, проводить самостоятельно и таким образом, например, ставить цену выше, например, 100 тысяч. Почему? Потому что
Игорь А.: провожу я. То есть я рекомендую, я веду, и я объясняю, что дальше. То есть быть этим куратором, можно назвать, либо психологом. То есть у нас все равно есть психологи, которых мы потом
Игорь А.: привлекаем, которые потом профориентацию это объясняют и говорят, что делать дальше. То есть такие профориентологи мы тоже привлекаем. То есть это тоже как внутренние возможности платформы.
Игорь А.: Я понимаю, где это может быть интересно, где это может быть неинтересно, но я как бы в любом случае рассказываю.
Игорь А.: Да, вот такая небольшая табличка, если говорить прям про деньги.
Игорь А.: сколько получаешь, например, с одной продажи. Мы переводим с самим процентом, потому что есть разные самозанятые и по этому физлица. То есть налог это уже как бы дело каждого и обязанность.
Игорь А.: Ну, в принципе, я сам тоже попробовал это все дело. Я, в общем, все делаю на себе. То есть я такой человек. Сначала прошел профориентацию. Так, почему -то у тебя старый лист. Одну секундочку,
Игорь А.: сейчас я еще раз открою, а то я уже там
Игорь А.: демонстрацию другого показываю. А у тебя еще на демонстрации чуть старенькая. Я тоже изначально прошел профориентации, потом понял вот этот весь путь, потом сам начал рекомендовать
Игорь А.: продавать. То есть, несмотря на то, что у меня немножко другой профиль, но я прям сначала сам все на себе пробую, тестирую, потом иду с этим предложением к людям. То есть достаточно
Игорь А.: легко на
Игорь А.: рекомендации семьи, с которой ты взаимодействуешь, а я тоже оказываю свои услуги, легко, достаточно продать. И я там от 20 до 35 тысяч вот этот путь сам прошел и говорю о том, что когда
Игорь А.: ты понимаешь ценность, а ценность ты начинаешь понимать, например, нужно немножко углубиться, понять, как у нас профориентация это проходит, это немножко другой созвон. Мы сейчас в
Игорь А.: рамках получасового созвона это все не успеем, но хотя это тоже важно. Ну и, соответственно, как приходят деньги, оплачивает семья, например, выдается отчет, все это внутри в кабинете,
Игорь А.: все видно, какая семья когда пришла, когда оплатила, на каком этапе они идут, то есть все завершилось, завершился, так сказать, цикл, и мы там через 14 дней выплачиваем, потому что
Игорь А.: некоторые могут возврат, потребовать еще что -то. То есть мы там 14 -дневный срок по закону выжидаем и делаем оплату.
Игорь А.: Дальше у нас, как я сказал, что есть личный кабинет, то есть там все достаточно прозрачно. Ты как, например, партнер, если тебе интересно подключиться, видишь, сама настраиваешь свои
Игорь А.: ссылки, лендинг формируется внутренний, формируется оффер цены, и ты можешь этих офферов и лендингов формировать внутри сколько угодно, то есть вплоть до того, чтобы вписывать для Алины,
Игорь А.: для Михаила и так далее. И там будет, например, вся информация о том, что именно ты рекомендуешь, вот твоя цена, вот ссылка. Либо промокод, то есть у нас тоже есть система промокодов
Игорь А.: внутренняя в кабинете, можно и по промокоду. И, соответственно, достаточно будет удобная гибкая система. Как я сказал, что создать все за минуту можно предложение, конструктор этот
Игорь А.: быстро все это формирует.
Игорь А.: По сути, то, что заказы, оформленные, все переходы, все обращения, все это внутри будет видно. Кто за что отвечает, соответственно, ты отвечаешь, например, за рекомендацию, мы отвечаем
Игорь А.: за исполнение всей услуги. и за нее не стыдно в целом.
Игорь А.: И опять же, про то, почему мы можем дороже продавать, каждый эксперт может ставить цену выше, потому что потом пройти обучение у нас внутри, например, и ставить свою цену, у нас некоторые
Игорь А.: продают по 150, по 200 тысяч, потому что считают, что консультация так стоит. Вот и
Юлия К.: все. Я поставлю следующий. Ну и соответственно есть вопросы, на которые мы опять же закрываем ответы. Почему дорого, если ребенку не понравится, неловко продавать. В общем, вот эти
Юлия К.: все вопросы я тоже сделаю такой внутренний чат для партнеров. И все это можно будет, там буду и я, и еще наши ребята из команды. И можно будет это все
Игорь А.: обсуждать, можно будет задавать в открытую. И, соответственно, что нужно сделать, чтобы подключиться? Ну, на данный момент у нас кабинет еще не готов.
Юлия К.: Все выходные уже там допиливали
Игорь А.: его. Я планировал, что будет ко встрече готов.
Юлия К.: Но самое главное, что если у тебя есть желание
Игорь А.: этого всего, то есть продолжить, то когда будет готов я могу
Юлия К.: прислать тебе ссылку для регистрации и дальше мы с тобой еще например можем
Игорь А.: созвониться проговорить я тебя проведу по
Юлия К.: самому кабинету и проговорим например кому -то и как можешь прислать эту ссылку из круга семей которые возможно это сейчас актуально
Юлия К.: да но и я пока не получила ответ на свой вопрос я озвучила стути люди с которыми я поступили не
Игорь А.: актуально поэтому я немножко в другом фармате оставляла наше сотрудничество я не очень понимаю чем
Игорь А.: да это все нормально все в порядке точнее то что я говорю так все юля вот ссылка подключайся задай еще раз вопрос и я попробую на него ответить я
Игорь А.: не очень поняла свою миссию в этом проекта.
Игорь А.: Если моя миссия в том, чтобы привлечь клиентов,
Игорь А.: то я, наверное, не вижу себя в этом.
Игорь А.: Я думала, что меня приглашают как эксперт, но здесь я вижу немножко другой запрос.
Игорь А.: Все верно. И как раз -таки партнерская программа – это одна из сторон. Сторону экспертов мы пока не обсуждали здесь, сейчас на встрече, потому что моя задача – презентовать партнерскую
Игорь А.: программу. Но как я начал говорить и в эту глубину не пошел, что эксперты на платформе у нас тоже будут. И как раз -таки это основная будет часть. То есть, по сути, это как профи .ру,
Игорь А.: условно говоря, только от Main Experts с клиентами не только Main Experts, но и других агентств, которые мы будем приглашать на платформу. То есть экспертом стать здесь достаточно легко,
Игорь А.: это не обязывает идти в партнерскую программу. То есть как эксперта, когда у нас будет готов, опять же, тоже функционал полностью платформы, на котором можно будет и
Юлия К.: вести звонки, у нас будет внутренняя система, которая, но она уже есть, мы тестируем на текущих клиентах, на некоторых. То есть часть функционала готова, то есть у нас, например, каждый
Юлия К.: звонок внутри системы тоже записывается, потом раскладывается
Игорь А.: на такой внутренний там профиль по различным характеристикам. И любой эксперт, который потом ведет нашего
Юлия К.: клиента, он видит весь этот
Игорь А.: профиль. То есть не нужно погружаться, например, понимать, что там на какой стадии. То есть есть summary, по которому можно понять, какой сейчас запрос и на какой стадии. То есть как
Игорь А.: эксперта это в любом случае мы вас приглашаем и будем рады видеть. А партнерская программа, то есть если нет сейчас понимания своей внутренней миссии и пользы, которую можно принести,
Игорь А.: то польза как минимум, как наши клиенты, которые используют эту профориентацию, это вход действительно в этот навигатор, чтобы далее построить правильный маршрут. То есть мы, в принципе,
Игорь А.: всегда начинаем с этого шага, чтобы потом нашим клиентам было удобно двигаться по правильному выбранному машину.
Игорь А.: Ну хорошо, если это как часть сотрудничества, оно имеет место быть. Я как бы обдумаю, да, и буду держать это в голове, кого из семи из клиентов я могу привести.
Игорь А.: Да, было бы замечательно, да, потому что в любом случае, чем... Это у меня шум такой какой -то, да?
Игорь А.: У меня ничего нет. Я не слышу, честно. Ладно, хорошо. То есть, действительно,
Игорь А.: чем больше семей начинают пользоваться нашим продуктом, тем больше есть синергия, потому что мы, по сути, вот у нас есть учителя по английскому, есть вы по дизайну, есть там по математике
Игорь А.: и так далее. Естественно, каждый из нас плюс -минус взаимодействует с какими -то семьями, которым Майн Эксперт сможет быть полезен. Соответственно, если вы говорите про пользу, то это
Игорь А.: однозначно то, что вот я, например, после того, как прошел, я просто порекомендовал нескольким семьям, они сразу купили, потому что понимают, что рекомендация от меня пришла. И действительно
Игорь А.: сейчас девочки 16 -15 лет начинают проходить этот путь, и естественно для них это
Юлия К.: лучше, чем если бы они, закончив школу, начали выбирать просто не понимая сильные стороны. Например, одна знакомая, мы в горы с ней ходим, говорит, слушай, у меня дочка хотела,
Игорь А.: очень хотела на ее респонденцию, они прям даже школу из -за этого поменяли в Казани. Они прошли такие, а ей подходит какое -то другое направление. Дочка сначала расстроилась, была в
Игорь А.: таком отказе, да как же так, я же хочу быть юристом, а ей сложно это дается. Ну и, в общем, с одной стороны, трудность, окей, иди в трудность, но с другой стороны, вот у тебя есть предрасположенность
Игорь А.: в другом пути, вот тебе показывает наша методология, вот он путь более легкий. Ну и сейчас со временем через одно -два касания уже вроде бы она такая, о, да, ну в принципе у меня бывали
Игорь А.: такие вот интересы. То есть меняется отношение ребенка к тому, к той информации, которая поступила изначально. То есть такое тоже бывает. У меня даже мои знакомые, которым я порекомендовал,
Игорь А.: сначала пошли в отказ, прям закрылись, а потом ничего страшного не случилось, просто не рассматривали этот вариант, даже не знали о том, что у ребенка есть способности. А
Игорь А.: сама программа профориентация – это сколько времени и что в нее входит? То есть это что именно? Это сеть серии консультаций или некоторые тестирования? Что это? Да, хорошо, расскажу
Игорь А.: немножко профориентация самой, что внутри продукта. В нем два теста. Это наша методология, но мы взяли за основу одну Big Five, другую Reosect. То есть мы, соответственно, понимаем
Игорь А.: по одной методологии, какие есть предрасположенности с точки зрения навыков, а с другой стороны мы понимаем, какие есть предрасположенности с точки зрения психологического состояния
Игорь А.: ребенка. И синтез этих данных дает понимание, во -первых, какие есть навыки и с чем они мэтчатся с точки зрения, какие есть профессии вообще в мире. С другой стороны, есть понимание
Игорь А.: того, что мы можем подобрать на учебный план на 5 лет правильный ВУЗ и правильную программу с теми навыками, которые есть сейчас и теми навыками, которые нужны, когда человек выйдет
Игорь А.: на работу. То есть профориентация, два теста для ребенка на основе BigFive и Reasec, плюс есть тесты для родителей. Как родители, каждый мама и папа, проходим еще дополнительный тест.
Игорь А.: Он больше накидывает на весь этот слой контекст. то есть как мы сами видим ребенка, как ребенок занят в школе, какие дополнительные занятия у него есть. То есть есть тесты для родителей,
Игорь А.: они там буквально на 5 минут, и есть тесты для ребенка. То есть тесты для ребенка, вот я говорю, мои дочки прошли их где -то за час,
Говорящий 3: 40 минут
Игорь А.: в час, вот так. На основании всех этих данных, соответственно, синтезируется отчет,
Игорь А.: и синтез этого отчета он как раз -таки разбирает. Ага, смотри, вот у твоей дочки, например, вот эти вот сильные стороны есть. Она, например,
Игорь А.: прямо линейная, у нее там предрасположенность к математике. Она вот такая, вот такая, вот такая, вот такая. И исходя из этого, есть вот такие навыки, которые используются в такой -то
Игорь А.: работе. А чтобы их развить, а есть вот такие направления, в которых она вообще не расположена. Это будет путь страдания. И чтобы развить вот эти навыки и прийти к той работе, на которой
Игорь А.: человек будет счастлив и развиваться, нужно учиться, например, на вот таких -то специальностях, потому что в таких -то вузах, в этих программах эти навыки развиваются. То есть профориентация
Игорь А.: как раз -таки точка входа в этот маршрут.
Игорь А.: И он как раз -таки сужает количество этих программ. И следующий шаг как раз -таки это уже идет подбор -бута, подбор программы. Вот такая -то, год отучились, ага, смотрим динамику. Опять
Игорь А.: же, зачем мы делаем эту платформу? Потому что в платформу все эти данные подгружаются. Какие успехи на таком -то курсе, на такой программе? Ага, а что нужно сделать, чтобы в итоге при
Игорь А.: выпуске ребенок смог получить ту работу, о которой хочет, мечтает и будет реализовываться. Нужны вот такие проекты, то есть внутри обучения. Дальше уже идет работа в течение 4 -5 лет
Игорь А.: как раз таки с клиентом по доведению его до той работы, которую он хочет. Но все это начинается с профориентации. часто начинается, я сам помню, когда поступал в ВУЗ, мне родители сказали,
Игорь А.: ты, главное, на бюджет куда -нибудь поступи.
Игорь А.: Я поступил, отучился 3 ,5 года, вот уже бакалавр светит, я такой, я не хочу
Говорящий 4: вообще, не
Игорь А.: хочу, не хочу. Я хотел заниматься компьютерами, а мне тут композиционные материалы рассказывают, вообще неинтересно. Я действительно бросил на второй курс, перепоступил и отучился на
Игорь А.: специальности, но уже в таком более осознанном возрасте, 19 лет, перепрошел этот путь. А условно говоря, и такие истории частые, когда ребенок теряет мотивацию, ему неинтересно и так
Игорь А.: далее, просто потому что родители выбрали профессию или вообще в целом неинтересно ему, или засунули в любой по рекомендации,
Юлия К.: по знакомству,
Игорь А.: а
Игорь А.: голос ребенка вообще тут не
Говорящий 4: учитывается. и, соответственно, профориентация, мне тоже просто почему откликнулось это все, я такой, если бы я прошел свое время, и родители мои бы увидели, я бы вот это оттуда, ну,
Говорящий 4: понятно, если бы так обы, но чуть -чуть по -другому легче бы было, потому что те страдания, которые были, с одной стороны, они меня сделали мной, с другой стороны, их могло не быть.
Говорящий 4: Да, понимаю, понимаю.
Говорящий 4: Так, Юлия, ну, не знаю, ответили или нет?
Говорящий 3: Да, ответили, ага.
Говорящий 4: Ну, в общем... Хорошо.
Говорящий 4: Хорошо. Тогда будем на связи. Залину можно... Мы, как у нас, будет тоже готова вся техническая составляющая. Я приглашу, покажу, что это будет интересно. Присоединишься, нет?
Говорящий 4: Все. Я понял. Хорошо, все, тогда на связи. Спасибо. Да, спасибо.